SASCHA PRUETER: So, just for
people who queued up in a line,
not knowing what session
this is, and have never
heard about live channels
or Android TV at all, so,
what is Android TV?
It's basically a
global TV platform
running on pure Android.
Actually, let me clarify
that a little bit.
It actually, it is just Android.
We extended the
Android framework
to support TV to be a
first class citizen.
This is not a bolt-on on top
of Android, or some hacky stuff
to make it work
on the big screen.
The core Android framework team
extended Android to make TV
a first class citizen.
That's important, because
all the Android developer
tools you know from
developing mobile apps,
developing tablet apps, maybe
developing where apps, they all
apply to Android TV as well.
It's the same SDK, it's the
same development environment,
it's all the same.
It's just Android.
And then, if you build
an app on Android TV,
you will have it on smart TVs.
You can see in our
sandbox, for example, there
are Sony smart TVs with
Android TV built in,
and we announced on Wednesday
a bunch of other partners.
These apps run on
pay TV set-top boxes.
We have a bunch of
partners internationally,
pay TV operators,
cable, satellite,
who run their set-top
box on Android TV.
But also, streaming
boxes, gaming
consoles, for example,
the NVIDIA Shield,
very popular device--
you build your app once
and it will run on
all of these devices.
And what does it actually mean?
Why should you even
interact with that?
When we launched Android
TV one and 1/2 years ago,
we introduced something
called the TV input framework
as part of the Android SDK.
And the TV Input
Framework, or short TIF,
brings traditional
TV functionality
to the Android TV platform.
So it allows you to interact
with things like HDMI inputs,
if your device has them.
It allows you to deal with stuff
like over-the-air channels,
channels in general, building a
program guide out of metadata,
reporting, all these things you
know from any traditional TV
device or your DVR,
they are in a framework
that you can use as
an app developer.
And to show you a little
bit how that looks like,
because it sounds very
abstract, we do a quick demo.
[DEMO PLAYING] So, once the
remote control-- So we're
actually running this.
This is a standard
retail Android TV device.
This is actually
a NVIDIA Shield.
And, you can see here, this
is just regular live TV
as you would know it.
It's program guides
with metadata, posters,
you see typical TV
content playing.
But the content
actually, in this case,
comes from applications.
So apps are actually
providing these live feeds.
You see, play movies as
a trailer channel now,
where you can watch the latest
trailers in an endless channel
and jump if you think
its interesting.
You can jump into the Play
Movies app to rent the movie.
There are examples here.
Bloomberg, The Weather
Channel, bringing
content in a nice linear
format to your device.
And it doesn't
matter which device,
if it's an ODT device like
this, if it's a Smart TV,
it works everywhere.
But what if you actually have
these channels and think,
well, I like this
thing with channels,
and just doing channel
up, channel down,
the traditional EPD guide,
the program guide, where
all my content is, but I would
like to have more content.
It's just the ones I
have, that's not enough.
Let's see what else there is.
And so, within the
TV application,
you can [DEMO STOPS PLAYING]
select Get More Channels,
and you see a selection of
apps that provide channels
into your TV Guide.
And so I just select, oh
wait, I know Haystack.
They provide a bunch of
interesting channels.
So let's see what they
are providing here.
So I just, very easy, like I
would do with any application,
I can select the
app and install it.
[DEMO PLAYING]
And if I'm back in the TV app,
the TV app already notifies me,
hey there's a new
content for us.
Do you want to add that?
And here you see all the
sources, and in this demo page,
it's just applications,
but that could also
be a built-in antenna or
cable tuner in the TV set.
Or it could be any
kind of ODT provider.
Here we see the application
we have just installed,
and we see, oh wow, ten
new channels I added.
And so, you see all these
channels showing up here,
and you can tune
to them, and it's
the experience is still very
much like a traditional TV
experience but merged together
with the new opportunities
we have with app
applications, and downloads,
and the play store.
So, I just wanted to show
that, so this abstract concept
actually gets a little bit
of a [INAUDIBLE] picture.
[DEMO STOPS PLAYING]
Going back to the slides.
One thing I wanted
to clarify is,
we talk a lot about live
content or linear content when
we talk about a channel.
That does not necessarily mean
that this content is actually
live.
As you saw some of the
examples that I just showed,
it might actually be, if
you have content as an app
developer, as a
content provider, that
is on-demand content,
but you think
it might actually make sense
to curate that into a channel.
For example, you have
a lot of music videos,
and you want to create
the country music
channel, or something like
that, for whatever reason
you would do that, you just,
you can curate that and provide
that as a channel from
your app into the TV Guide.
And so, live content can
live, but it can also
be curated content just put
together into a linear stream.
Both of these concepts are
interesting for consumers.
So, who can benefit from that?
On the one hand, I
already mentioned
the TV input framework and
the concept of live channels
is very, very much designed
for hardware manufacturers.
So OEMs can actually
integrate physical tuners
like satellite
tuners, cable tuners.
We have partners who actually
ship TV sets with a satellite
tuner built in.
And so, with the
TV input framework,
they can integrate
these hardware tuners
with a standard
API, and no matter
what they change underneath,
the application layer
always stays the same.
Their TV app always
stays the same.
They don't have to modify that.
They just change
the hardware layer,
the tuner layer underneath it.
For consumers, this
is really interesting
because a lot of consumers, I
know we here especially at I/O,
we love apps, we love
to download apps and use
a lot of them.
But a lot of users really like
just to sit down on the sofa,
flip through the program guide,
use channel up, channel down.
They don't want to jump
through five different apps
to get to the one
content they want.
They actually really like that
the concept of navigation,
of approaching content,
is exactly the same
with every channel, no matter
where the channel comes from.
So we see lots of
good feedback on that.
And also then in the end
for you, for app developers,
it provides an additional new
entry point to your content,
like I mentioned with the
Play Movie trailer channel
as an example.
This is a live channel exposed
by the play movies app.
So it just shows trailers,
but with our concept of app
linking, they have
an entry point.
The user can click, oh, I
now want to jump into the app
and rent that content.
So that gives you users who
are traditionally maybe not
app users, who would not launch
a lot of apps, that are just,
the majority of time,
sitting in the program guide,
using channel up,
channel down, and that's
how they approach content.
So for these kind
of users, this is
a new way you can bring your
app, your content, to them.
And actually, we work
with a bunch of partners.
I was just talking last
week with the developers
from the app I just
showed, Haystack.
With their last app update,
they exposed live channels.
And they said that, within
the first month of them adding
the live channel functionality,
it's already driving over
10% of watch time across all
users they have on Android
TV, and 16% for new users.
So it is definitely a great
new entry point for consumers
to consume that content.
Also, because I get asked a lot
of times, well, live channels,
is Google really doing
something about that or not?
So, we are
continuously investing
into the TV input framework
and the live channels app.
We originally started
with Android Lollipop
when we introduced
the TV input framework
in its very basic form.
With Marshmallow, we got a
lot of feedback from partners
and addressed a lot of small
issues, under the cover polish.
We introduced time-shifting API.
It's already back in Android
M. And now, with the upcoming
Android N, we're adding more
features to the TV input
framework, like the
recording functionality,
that where application
developers can use TV input
framework, APIs, to
manage their recordings.
And so, also to come back,
because a lot of people
ask, well, especially
application developers who
come from mobile,
is live TV watching,
is this program
guide, these channels,
that's an old thing, right?
Like, who does that anymore?
So this is from the
last Nielsen report,
their total audience
report they do once a year,
this is from 2015.
And it shows, even in
households with connected TVs,
or TVs that have devices
connected to the internet
so they can watch OTT content
from the internet, the majority
of watch time, like really
a lot of the watch time,
is still traditional live TV.
So this is a big
audience, and we think you
as application developer really
should capture that audience.
And that's what we provide
the TV input framework.
And also, the examples I
showed earlier in the demo
are from the US, and these are
single channels and interest
channels exported
by certain apps.
We also have some
great examples.
For example, in Europe, we
have a partner there, Zattoo,
who, they offer a whole
cable channel lineup over
as OTT channels.
And they have the app
around for a while,
they brought it to Android
TV and other TV platforms,
and they integrate with
the TV input framework.
So, basically, you install that,
and with your subscription,
you have all your cable channels
on your Android TV device
in the live channels app.
And as I mentioned before,
what's really great
is it gives you also the ability
to drive users from the live TV
experience, from the
live channels experience,
into your app.
You see on the lower side
here, the Zattoo icon, this
is our app-linking functionality
in the live channels app,
where the user easily
can jump into the app
and get more
content-- for example,
on-demand archives that
your app is providing,
or additional functionality
that is not exposed
by the live channels app.
But to talk a little bit more
about the actual real stuff,
the developer stuff,
that happens underneath,
handing over to Jae.
JAE SEO: Hi, I'm Jae.
So, you just heard
a lot of good things
about the TV input framework.
Now, you might wonder, what
exactly is the TV input
framework?
OK, that's what I'm
going to explain to you.
First, let me briefly talk
about the overall architecture
of the TV input framework to
help you better understand
the rest of this talk.
Let's just start
with the data path.
When we say data,
in the TV framework,
we're talking about channel
and program metadata that
describe TV channels and
programs, such as channel
numbers, cosigns, channel
logos, program titles, start
and end times of each
program, and so on.
On the top left of the
diagram is the app called
Live Channels, which is an
Android app that people use
every day for watching live TV.
We sometimes call it a TV player
app, just like media player,
because it plays whatever
TV content the user wants.
One thing to note here
is that the Live Channels
app is Google's reference
implementation of a TV player,
and TV OEMs have
freedom to choose
their own implementation, just
like the dial apps on phones.
So, the Live Channels app
doesn't have any actual TV
content.
Where do they come from?
They come from the channel
apps on the top right.
Then how is the data path?
How does the Live Channel
stream know all the channel
and program information?
It's easy.
Channel apps put their own
channel and program data
into the system database,
and the Live Channels app
reads them from there.
Next, let's talk about
the control path.
When the user choose the channel
through the Live Channels app,
and it happens to be
one of the channels
that your channel app provides,
we call you and say, please
play channel XYZ.
And we expect you to start
playback of the live content
on that channel.
Technically, we give you an
Android surface object on which
you can render your video.
Once you tell us the video
is ready, we take the surface
and we draw some
overlays, if necessary,
such as channel banner,
and we show it to the user.
That's it, simple.
You can find the actual APIs
included in the live TV input
framework under the package
name Android.media.tv.
There are many classes,
a bunch of methods,
callbacks, constants, and so on.
But what you should remember
as a channel app developer
are just two Java classes,
TvContract, and TvInputService.
TvContract is the class that
defines channel and program
columns for the system database.
And the TvInputService
is the class
that you need to implement
in order to provide
TV channels on Android TV.
Before we talk about
how you can start
integrating your app
with the TV framework,
let me clarify one thing.
When you look at the TV input
framework APIs in more detail,
you'll be surprised to see
they are just Java interfaces,
and the business logic
is not actually there.
Let me tell you, we're launching
the new TV recording APIs
in the TV input
framework this year.
And the most
questions we get are
like, where is the actual
recording happening?
Where do you
schedule recordings?
Where do you handle
resource conflicts?
Something like that.
The answer to all
of those questions
is that it's in
either Live Channels
or individual TvInputServices.
Why is that?
Why did we make such a decision?
That's because when we first
designed the framework,
we really wanted to
be flexible in terms
of updating our offering.
It's easy for app developers
to update things themselves
instead of relying
on the system update.
By our bundling the business
logic from the Android platform
and putting it
into live channels
or delegating to
TvInputServices,
we are able to push any
new update at any time.
OK, let's talk about how you can
start integrating with the TV
input framework.
The first thing you
should do is take a look
at the code samples, of course.
We highly recommend that
you use Android Studio.
When you run Android studio,
in the very first screen,
you can import samples.
You just type TV, and
you see two samples
we provide under Android TV.
And the one with the title
Sample TV Channel App
using TV input framework,
that's the one you need.
You put that sample,
and you're ready to go.
This is the optimal
development flow, we think.
Once you have the
code sample, you
can start changing resources
such as XML files, streams,
and images, in addition
to the package name.
Just don't forget to
change the package name.
You can't be working for
the company named Example.
Once you're done
with the resources,
then you can build a sample
and [? plant ?] in yours.
That's it.
Of course, you need to
provide detailed descriptions
of your channels,
programs, including
the URIs for your live
videos, but you're not even
touching the code.
Is that simple.
But maybe, there might
be some other reasons
that you must modify the code.
For example, if you just can't
use AXL player in the sample
for video playback, then
you should replace it with
your in-house media player by
[? n-Stream. ?] Or maybe you
just had a code and
want to re-write it,
which is totally normal, then
please go ahead and modify
the code.
Lastly, if you already
have your Android TV app,
then you can simply add the
TvInputService sample here
to your existing app by
simply declaring the service
in your Android manifest file.
And you're all set.
So, we have just skimmed through
the very basics of the TV input
framework.
I'll hand over to Ibrahim
for more technical details
and our best features.
IBRAHIM KARAHAN: Thanks, Jae.
So far, we covered the
background and history
of Android TV, live TV,
live channels and TV input
framework, Sascha
gave the motivations
of building such applications,
from the user developers
and hardware developers,
hardware OEM,
the original equipment
manufacturers' perspectives.
And Jae gave a
technical overview
of the TV input framework.
So now it's time
actually looking
at how we implement
this live channel.
It's really important then
you start with the sample.
It's an actual full application.
It actually builds and you
can install it on your device,
and will start running
the moment you actually
click on the Live
Channels application.
That happens because you
define in your application,
you define your manifest.
You say that I had
this service, and it's
going to be read by the
Live Channels application
to show up this page.
Here, the first time you
launch the live application,
you'll see the available
sources in your device.
By default, most of
the Nexus devices
come up with the
Google Play Movies
and TV application
live channel source.
The second one is our Rich
Input, which is our sample.
Once you click on
one of them, it
runs a special
activity that sets up
the necessary metadata that's
read by TV input framework.
And then your channel is ready,
and you will start to get up
and running.
So this is the manifest
part that you need
to add into your application.
The important thing is, you
need to create a service that
extends from TvInputService.
You need to add an
intent filter called
Android.media.tv.TvInputService.
The other information
that you need to provide
is this metadata called
Android.media.tv.input.
It's an XML file, and in
it, you have to tell us,
you have to tell the
input framework which
activity to run when the user
tries to set up a source.
If you look at this sample
application, the sample
activity here, this
is really simple.
There's no UI involved.
The only thing that you
have is, basically, you just
need to set up the sources.
The thing that you
need to know here
is TV input framework exposes
all its metadata, channel data,
with a content provider.
And as Jae mentioned
before, TV contract
is a basic database that
contains everything.
Like poster data, channel
information, the program
information that you fill in,
and basically once you populate
those information, you
just need to put it
into the content provider.
So if you look at this file,
what we do is basically
create a content values object.
And then, at the
input ID, the name
of your channel,
the Display Number,
then just get the
content resolver
and then just push it in.
Another thing is, you don't have
to have separate applications
if you have multiple channels.
Just like we saw in
the Haystack example,
once you click and create
this activity, when it runs,
you can just repeat
this thing a few times,
how many channels you
have, and then all of them
will be available for
viewing for the users.
Of course, this example
does not contain any UI,
but if you think that you're
doing a lot of processing
in this file, you can
show a nice logo screen,
and then let your users know
that you are doing something
while the channels
are being set up.
The next thing is the life
cycle of the TV input service
that you're implementing.
Everything starts
with the launch
of live channels application.
So the main activities,
onCreate method is run,
and at some point the
onset surface method
is called, which sets the
surface that your media
player is going to use
for showing the video.
At some point, if there are
already some sources set up,
it's going to try to tune
to one of those channels.
Those light blue
boxes are the things
that you are responsible for.
The first one is
the onTune method.
The onTune method
is where you get
the channel URI that
you need to tune to,
and then you need to get
the channel information.
It's just the URI.
Then you need to get
where the video is
going to be played from, if
you have any captions, what
is the title of the channel.
You're going to get it from
this database that you're using.
Can be content provider, it
can be some other database,
or you can just get
it from the web.
Now, you need to check if your
program is still available.
By available, I mean if it's
still available for viewing,
if the media is available,
or it can be blocked.
So you may have some
age-restricted content.
So it is possible that the media
controls, parental controls
are set up, and it's not really
suitable for the user to view.
If everything is
good, then you need
to create your
media player object.
You set it up with the
video link, the captions,
and tell the media player that
this is the surface that you
need to show the video to.
And the onTune method
will be almost done.
The next thing is, since
your responsibility is over,
you need to tell the
system what to do next.
So we provide, in
TV input framework,
some methods that
start with notify.
So some examples are notify
video available, for example.
This, you need to call this,
when everything is good.
So you have the program,
everything's running,
your media player is running,
and you've prepared everything.
The next thing is just telling
the TV input framework, OK, I'm
ready.
Just show it to the user.
Other stuff, like age-restricted
content, was another example.
You can't show this to the user.
So you need to tell the system
that, hey, my content is
blocked.
I can't show it to the user.
Please handle it.
And you say, notify
content blocked.
TV input framework
takes this comment
and shows the parental
controls dialogue, the lock so
that the user can
either unlock the screen
or switch to another channel.
And this is the life cycle
of the live channels.
Of course, there's one more
thing, the onRelease method.
That's where you need
to be a good citizen
and clear out any resources
that you may be using.
So this is a sample
TvInputService implementation.
As I told you, it's
the onTune method
that you need to override.
You get the channel URI,
get your source, somehow,
from content provider
database, and then the rest
is basically media
player-specific.
This sample code that we
provide comes with AXL player.
Everything is already set
up, you can just use this.
You may choose to use
other sources, depending
on your content.
You may actually ship
your own media player.
Then you need to
change this place,
and set it up appropriately.
And once everything
is done, you need
to call one of
the notify methods
so that TV input
framework takes over.
This is it.
This is the basic things that
you need to get a channel up
and running.
We actually have more than that.
We have advanced features,
such as the [? only ?] view,
and the app-linking card, and
the now playing card actually.
[DEMO PLAYING] You want to
make a demo with the-- Sorry.
You're gonna make a demo of
the Google Play Movies and TV
channel.
So basically, this live
channel is an endless stream
of trailers that you can rent
or buy from Google Play Movies.
So we have lots
of trailers here.
This is "The Last Witch Hunter."
And also, these videos are
available in other sources
like YouTube, right?
What we show here is the name of
the movie, the year, the length
of the content, the current
ranking of the movie,
and the current price to rent
it from Google Play Movies.
You can achieve the same thing
by embedding the information
right into the video, right?
And that will make
the same effect.
But the thing here is, this
is actually dynamic content,
right?
So your users will
watch this movie,
they may add their ranking,
make it go up or go down.
Or, you may have a discount.
Tomorrow, it could
be $2.99, right?
If you do embed this
into the video, that's
going to create another hassle.
It means that you have
to reprocess this video,
change the source, and do it
again and again as it changes.
What [? this ?]
[? whole idea ?] is an overlay.
So you can use this tool to
overlay any kind of information
on top of the video.
One of our partners,
actually, is really clever,
that they work
with the providers.
They use this screen to show
the local weather information
for user's location.
They get the location
information from Android,
and then put the next
three days' weather
information, no matter what
they're showing currently
on screen.
The other thing
is, this actually
happens if I just click
on the center button,
so I should have
talked about this,
this is the app-linking card.
It is the most
powerful thing that you
can do to add interactivity
to your live channels.
So it basically
gives you a chance
to run any Android
intent upon click.
And you can also customize
this badge, right?
You can change, so it
changed actually, we
moved to another server here,
so now it's showing "Zoolander."
It changed the icon, it
changed the poster image,
and it actually shows
the price information
to buy this from Google Play.
And with one click, it's
going to [DEMO STOPS PLAYING]
just take you to the
companion application.
And if I liked
this movie, I said
OK, I want to look
at more information.
I want to see what
this is about,
and I can just here buy or rent,
and start watching right away.
So it's a great place
to add interactivity
to your live
channels application.
And finally, [DEMO PLAYING]
we, upon click
with the Home button, you
can go to home screen.
Sometimes you need to do
something else with your TV.
By default, live channels come
with now playing card data.
And you can change
the logo, you can
change the title of
this now playing card,
and a click takes you
back to the live channel.
Now let's talk about the
implementation of these.
[DEMO STOPS PLAYING] Editing
overlay view is quite simple.
The first thing that you
need to do is basically,
in onCreateSession, you need
to tell TV input framework
that your session has an overlay
view with setOverlayViewEnabled
(true), and then
you need to override
the onCreateOverlayView.
You inflate a view here,
and just return it.
If you keep a
handle to the view,
you can just use this
in the later stages
throughout the life
cycle of your service,
and dynamically
change the information
that's shown on the overlay.
The other one is the
app-linking badge.
It's completely in your control.
You can change
the color, you can
change the poster, the texts,
the card color, and your icon.
And this is really simple.
You just need to fill in the
app underscore link columns when
you're populating, when you're
setting up your channel,
and it will automatically
show this app badge
with this information.
And I told you
earlier, now playing
card is completely automatic.
Before I finish, I
want to talk about how
to reach your TV audience.
There are two ways
of achieving this.
The first one is, basically,
using the Google Play Store.
It's the default way of
getting more channels,
more applications for
your Android devices
and your Android TV.
Basically, if you
have an application,
already have an application,
just, as Jae said,
just add this service into
your existing applications
and update your APK,
and that's going
to be available in the
live channels application
to be download.
Or if you don't have
one, create a new listing
and upload your APK,
and that's going
to be available for
your users to use.
Oh, the other way
is-- we've seen this
with lots of our partners.
They work together with OEMs,
the hardware manufacturers,
like TV manufacturers, the
player manufacturers, setup box
manufacturers, and they
bundle their application
with the device itself.
So it creates an out-of-box
experience for those devices.
Like, you may be the
default weather provider
for this TV set, for example.
Thank you for listening to us.
Our talk is over.
Please, visit our
sandbox in Zone A.
We want to talk to
you RPM [INAUDIBLE]
and our engineers
want to talk to you
and get your opinion
about Android TV
and want to learn
about your use cases.
We also have
resources on the web.
We have the G+ community at
g.co/AndroidTvDev where you can
ask and answer questions,
and join the community.
We have training in
developer.android.com/training
for building TV
channels, and finally,
our sample application
is hosted at GitHub.
[MUSIC PLAYING]